[Applaudissements]
allez on va jouer quel endroit
improbable sera inauguré les chéres on
va jouer bien sûr avec toute lactue vous
allez tout savoir quand vous regardez t
PMP après normalement vous savez tout ce
qui s'est passé dans la journée en plus
vous avez des toilettes magnifiques des
tenues exceptionnelles autour de la
table donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours
bien voilà pour l'œil pour le
téléspectateur toujours d'avoir des gens
non mais c'est vrai c'est toujours non
mais c'est important d'avoir des gens
bien habillés et voilà et c'est vrai que
merci
merci quel endroit improbable sera
inauguré en 2027 un squat dans le salon
de gillevert
une ville immergée dans l'océan
Atlantique une piste cyclable sur la
scène ou un hôtel dans l'espace
oui ça a changé ou je peux répondre tout
de suite la D
d c'est
[Applaudissements]
mythique ça aussi c'est toujours
pareil
elle est
cont allez il est 21h elle est pas
encore sortie mich Marie on Michel Marie
j'adore
s les chauss déjà temps de revenirme de
revenir c'est déjà temps de revenir s
déconn je peux répond de là-bas bah
répond de là-bas je peux oui c'est quoi
la réponse ah la d un hôtel dans
l'espace bravo très
bon
ça devra faire toutes ces réponses
là-bas c'est fou à mon avis dès que tu
veux répondre tu vas là-bas allez c'est
une bonne réponse et oui un hôtel dans
l'espace devrait ouvrir en 2027 c'est un
truc de fou avec salle de sport cinéma
space ça fait rêver tout le monde moi ça
me chauffe à fond je sais pas combien ça
coûte cette connerie mais on va voir pas
encore le prix pour l'instant bah
t'inquiète pas le prix à mon avis ça va
ça va te coûter bon
parti trouver le bon hôtel quand on part
en vacances peut parfois être un
véritable casse-tête et cette fois-ci
c'est une une destination insolide qui
est au goût du
jour car après les premiers vols
spatiaux touristiques une entreprise
américaine souhaite aller encore plus
loin en proposant un hôtel de luxe dans
l'espace ah ou d'accord à mi-chemin
entre le voyage touristique et
d'affaires l'établissement prévu pour
2027 pourrait accueillir 400 personnes
et proposera des bureaux des suites des
restaurants des salles de sport un
cinéma ou encore un spa si le prix de
cet hôtel à l'architecture circulaire et
au niveau de gravité différent n'a pas
encore été dévoilé certains ont déjà
émis quelques hypothèses et craignent
que cette destination soit loin d'être
accessible pour tout le
monde combien 50 millions de
dollars 50 millions de dollars 50 milli
50 millions de dollars par personne 50
millions de dollars pourquoi pour une
semaine par personne pour une
semaine
voyage pourquoi moi je vais dans une
Renault Espace pu c'est tout oui alors
ça fait 488 m de diamètre d'accord ça
coûte une fortune il y aura même une
salle de concert une bibliothèque ma
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va [__]
là-bas pourquoi est-ce qu'on donne pas
cet argent au nécessiteux c'est une
fortune qu'on dépense dans l'espace quel
rapport l'ARG mais qu'est-ce que tu
racontes c'est pas de l'argent
publicorte quoi pas de l'argent il dit
encore n'importe quoi il dit encore
n'importe
quo alors ça veut dire un mec demain
donc demain un mec tu vas qui fait des
des voitures de sport Ferrari tu vas lui
dire mais pourquoi tu fais des voitures
de mais frèrees en fait en fait tu es
devenu build je cro j'ai bien compris
que c'est de l'argent privé mais celui
qui a tout cet argent privé qu'est-ce
qu' va construire un hôtel spatial il a
150 membres d'équipage il aa 400 pr tu
fa
plus on arrête mission et on arrête ta
connerie tu sa quoiain de devenir fou
esain de basculer tu vas prendre un
petit peu de congé toi de
semaines deue économique c'est un parce
qu'en plus g ça va créer des emplois ça
va créer de la richesse c'est
extraordinaire aprèsah oui ça va créer
des emplois bien traver à une autre
formule peut-être dès 2025 avec moins de
moins de passagers une trentaine de
passagers une semaine je sais pas si
mais non mais demain il va dire demain
il va te dire ouais mais attends tu as
acheté ta chemise pourquoi il vend des
chemises mais tu peux demander tu peux
aussi demander à Gill quand tu achètes
des chaussures de luxe à ta femme
qu'est-ce que tu fait bah ouais
exactement bah il fait le pigeon comme
d'habitudeah c'est pareil une peti hôel
spatial qui vaut des milliards
maistilé pas de bêtises c'est justement
c'est le progrès mais tu es fou quoi
après d'un point de vue philosophique il
a quand même untit peu raison c'est
quand même un getto pour les
multimilliardaires dire qu'en fait les
multimilardaires s'inventent des nouveau
loisirs c'est le monde de demain ça va
plus tu crois vraiment que nos enfants
nos petits enfants vont pouvoir aller
dans des hôels
comme dans
ansû cétait inimaginable et dans 50 ans
on peut tout à fait l'imaginer ils sont
en train de travailler dessus il y a TR
projets améain crois s quand elle voyait
le métro elle croyait qu'elle avir des
métos quand elle était en diligence les
écrans de télé on salout ou écrél
Salou CIS qu'elle Savit que jearri
habiller comme ça non oui alors moi je
vais mettre en péril ma PL siôt revenue
parce que je suis un peu d'accord avec
pas pour la même raison avec Gill mais
en revanche et si on pouvait essayer
juste de préserver la terre avant de
s'envoyer en l'IR parce que franchement
je trouve qu'il y a plus urg un je non
ouime TR vérité énergétiquement parlant
qu'est-ce qu'on balance comme merde rest
pour une élite ça restera pour une élite
et puis
voilà sepond à Patrick là non mais je
veux même pas répondre c'est tellement
bas tellement
débile n en fait là on dirait qu'il on
dirait que cétait une vanne ouais bah
oui mais pas une malheureusement mais
moi ce qui m'inquiète surtout c'est que
quand on veut défier les éléments comme
ça ça se termine toujours en catastrhe
ça on a voulu lancer la la première
navette spatiale Challenger challenger
boom on a mis une institutrice tout le
monde regarde les écoles bom elle
explose en vol le sous-mar on a voulu
démocratiser l'évereste sont partis en
96 Bou 27 morts Bou dans dans 2 jours
voilà on a voulu descendre sur le
Titanic des profondeurs extrêmees boum
la le Nautilus là comment il Sapp
Nautilus tout le monde mort et ca là on
VO dans l'espace et ben c'est une
catastrophe annoncée tu peux don un
conseil pour la suite donner moins
d'exemples ah
merde en de on avit
compris sur leond il a raison un peu
moin un peu moins aussi on comprenait
aussi ou alors un mot sur deux peut-être
ça passerit mieux moi j'ai une question
c'est comment est-ce que comment est-ce
qu'on va faire du sport en appesanteur
bah facile alors ils vont créer une
apesanteur enfin ils vont créer un
système évidemment AR ce sera comme si
tuétais dans un hôel normal si quand tu
sors par contre tu dégoles quand tu sors
de l'hôtel bien sûr a des Bou
chaneloroi c'est pour ça que c'est le
monde de demain ils sont en train de
travailler sur des
choses pas pour être en apaisanteur il y
a aucun intérêt auog et puis voilà il et
surtout que
allez allez on y va une autre question
vou la placer à quoi sert la machine
dans laquelle se trouve cet homme oh
regardez-le voyez
c'est non non mais c'est pas lui il lu
ressemble ça pas l'air très moderne ah
tu sais déjà
[Musique]
toi c'est toi qui chante non c'est lui
non non la dénonce balance deuxième
langue non c'est lui allez elle sert à
laver les vêtements directement sur soi
à se réchauffer les glouis en
hiver à se couper les cheveux ou à
recycler les flatulantes en énergie
verte benim qui a été la première c'est
mon domaine de prédilection chef s'agit
des cheveux se couper les cheveux
exactement c'est incroyable mais vrai
mais un nouveau robot coiffeur pourra
bientôt s'occuper de vos cheveux c'est
un truc de fou et euh ça ça ça ça ça ça
je suis pas content je suis pas content
parce qu'il y a Sora quand même qui est
avec nous
même cy l'intérêt d'aller chez le
coiffeur aussi c'est le rapport humain
on parle de de la vie on parle de la
voisine de ceci de cela c'est c'est une
petite bulle c'est un moment où on se
pose c'est pas pour être avec un robot
pourêtre avec un être humain
moment
l'argent de la machine ils auraent dû le
donner aux gens bien c'est que quand
vous quand vous allez chez le coiffeur
il vous coupe les cheveux vous avez
toujours plein de cheveux sur vous vous
êtes dégueulasse alors que là ils
aspirent en temps réel tous les cheveux
donc vous avez aucun cheveux sur vous ça
c'est plutô pas mal pens un pe la
robotisation des pizzas où il y avait
plus les pizzas y exactement et puis là
oh là là là si tu veux avec Jean-Michel
mer dernièrement non non je suis en
train de buger là non non ce que je
disais c'est que si le le robot part en
vrille bah ça peut être dans Dereux ah
tu l'as essayé tu l' essayé la machine
toi vis blanc tu l'as essayé non non
mais i parce qu'il a peur que ça coupe
la tête mais
oui bien sûr quoi oui g non évidemment
que c'est dangereux le gars il
travaillit dans une entreprise
d'imprimante pendant le covid il lance
ça il y a des ciseaux qui peuvent vous
couper moi je ne comprends pas que ce
produit puisse être commercial cont to
tu devis peut-être essayer je te le dis
c'est vrai j'ai peur de ça non vraiment
oui ça te plaît ça pas du tout regardez
ça part dans tous les sens qui maîtrise
c'est quoi le truc quel est le conseil
métier des
coi tu pass une
bonnemission regard cet extrait de
l'amour est dans le Pr cétait
hierour dans le Pr peut-être l'année
prochaine sera l'amour vu du
Pr éé radio télégraphiste dans les
Télécom alors
qui va faire une entrée fracassante chez
Christine l'éleveuse de chien un gars de
patron incogno un gars de patron
incognito qui s'est gouré d'émission
Jacques cardos pour tourner sa nouvelle
émission complément
dans un S de Johnny prê en découdre ou
l'ex de Christine qui sort tout juste du
placard
alors qui saz pas ça non la c la C vous
dites l' de Christine
regardez a donc été radio télégraphiste
dans les
Télécom
[Musique]
alors
regardez regardez du commandement du
commandement alors en parlant de laamour
dans le Pr vous a sélectionné les trois
moments qui ont fait le plus parler sur
les réseaux sociaux hier on commence
avec le producteur de fourrage Roméo
four Roméo Roro le rigolo lui alors
clairement il est là vraiment pour pécho
mais aussi pour la rigolade et les
imitations et je peux vous dire que
c'est pas le dernier regardez
écé je suis trompé de trous çave
deso j'en Mar de toi alors Sophie
aimerait bien qu'il se montre un peu
plus cochon allez s'il te
plaît j'adore j'adore
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore surnom c'est Roro le
psycho psycho parce que souvenez-vous
c'est lui qui s'était ramené chez
l'agricultrice avec une pelle un couteau
à désosser et un détecteur de maison
jamais compris pourquoi ah bah là pour
conquérir la jolie éleveuse de chèvre il
lui a proposé une activité pas ouf ouf
regardez du coup tu es obligé de marcher
doucement en fait ouais ça me change
c'est ça tu balayes tu es obligé de le
faire doucement tu as pas le choix je
trouve ça très curieux il est pas du
tout dans la séduction il est plus un
peu dans la démonstration de ce qui sait
faire de et de ce qu'il est moi je c'est
pas ce que j'attends c'est grand c'est
grand ouais ok ça commence là ouais ça
s'arrête là
ok
ah
joli et voilà le câbl électrique ok très
[Applaudissements]
bien non mais le gars le gars a fait
tout ça pour trouver un câble
électrique charer non mais un détecteur
de Méau mais c'est quoi ça ou moi je
trouve ça chouette il lui partage sa
passion ça crée des liens c'estelle qui
est un petit peu sur la déf trouver un
butin oui moi je pense qu'elle le kiffe
pas parce que sinon elle aimerait
partirer des choses avec lui non mais
c'est sûr je dire façon une meuf quand
elle te kiffe tu peux lui faire faire
comme un mec fait faire n'importe quoi
une meuf pe t'assurer qu'il aurait
trouvé un trésor et c'est resté avec
avec il est pas comme ça pas comme
ça elle préfère l'autre elle préfère
l'autre non il est pas sympa il est pas
très tactile elle l'aime pas trop il est
pas en séduction
elle elle préférait lui en speedting
mais maintenant elle est branchée vers
l'autre exactement on on aime bien cette
émission quand même on kiffe he on kiffe
pas moi et quoi non pas Géral toi tu as
la tenue pourou ouais je suis d'accord
une tenue une tenue fermière mais non
mais c'est vrai non mais ça te va bien
ma chérie enfin on va terminer avec
Christine et Alain qu' on a vu tout à
l'heure avec le gars au look improbable
Alain arrive donc chez Christine
l'éleveuse de chien en direct il lui
fait une déclaration ça part un bon
sentiment ça part bien sauf que
Christine elle s'en bat un peu les reins
euh en fait lalin c'est un petit peu le
le le muskin du jour regardez allez tu
Meux suiv il y a quelque chose que je
voulais te dire'estce dire je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'il y a en toi mais tu mais
tu as chviré mon cœur ah d'accord comme
si le monde s'était arrêté tu vois de de
quelque chose tu m'as fait un quelque
chose que je peux pas arriver à à
définir attends on va sortir la chienne
elle va me manger les les fils
électriques là bien là et voilà bon on
on aura plein de choses à se raconter
déjà il y aura du boulot quoi
ouais grosse il y a une grosse
différence d'âge et elle se pose
beaucoup de questions sur lui il est
arrivé avec ses charantesses ses sabot
c'était pas très sexy quoi donc elle a
tendance un peu à le bâcher ouais ouais
c'est ça merci alors les audiences
d'hier en 5e position il y avait W9 avec
un film red quelqu'un qui plus d'osï
rien r impitoyable sur France 3 1,5
million infiltré sur France 2 qui a
beaucoup baissé France 2 12% est dans le
prê 3,8 million et les yeux grand fermés
sur TF1 petite déception hein pour la le
feuilleton de TF1 que c'était ils ont
fait beaucoup de com avec marial Robin
tout ça petite déception 3,9 millions
juste juste 100000 de plus que Laam dans
prè il faut savoir que laamour est dans
le Pr en plus est leader he sur toutes
les cibles commerciales comme on dit
c'est important de vous le dire ça parce
que en fait les chaînes et surtout M6
ils regardent pas le Global il garde son
vent des cibles donc les les gens qui
ont entre 25 et 49 ans puisque pour eux
ce sont ceux qui me le plus voilà o les
15 49 ans voilà ce qu'on appelle la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans et c'est
vrai que sur cette cible là M si c'était
largement leader donc TF1 petite
déception encore une fois pour TF1 on va
se retrouver dans un instant les chériis
avec les infos du jour le top 3 des
infos du jour et on a du lourd et on a
des nouvelles de Marwan Beren oui
l'acteur de Plus belle la vie c'est vrai
que c'est c'est dramatique toujours pas
de nouvell mais il y a des news à tout
de suite
[Applaudissements]
wiighton